did you ever say to you this amount that
we're actually going to pay this 700 and
whatever thousand okay it's kind of
between what you'd pay if you did it
instantly instantly or what you'd paid
if you waited the whole time okay what's
happening is the interest and your
repayments they're kind of playing
tug-of-war right the interest is getting
bigger but hopefully you're putting in
payments to reduce that so that your
payments sort of balance out the
interest that's coming on right so I
want you to see how this is happening
month by month because that's how
frequently you pay read this with me and
you'll need your calculator a home loan
of $250,000 that's important is taken
out at this interest rate with a monthly
payment of 1888 use the table to
calculate the amount still owing okay so
this table is a structure for us to help
us understand what is happening we can
go through it left to right top to
bottom you start with this principle
right and the first thing that happens
the first thing that always happens is
the bank will charge your interest okay
now have a look at this this is
happening on monthly basis right so with
your calculator there you can say that
the interest will be 250,000 right times
what's the rate
what's the rate it's seven point seven
five so I'm going to write in my
calculator but zero point sorry that's
just 250,000 times zero point zero seven
five but it's only a month right it's a
lot a whole year so the N is going to be
one over twelve okay do you see that so
that number there that's the first
little batch of interest they're going
to charge me
okay so you go ahead and punch that in
okay so the number I'm looking at is one
thousand five hundred and sixty two
dollars and fifty cents yeah what have I
done oh you are right absolutely and
it's good that means it's gonna be a
little more so it's seven point seven
five percent so let's check Betty oh
sorry
yeah I'm cheating okay so when you fix
your number up let's fix my number up is
it an awkward number I'm getting this
yep they're looking good okay good so
what happens is that now that that
interest has been calculated the bank is
like you owe us more now you owe us the
sum of those two things which is why
this next column says p plus i you see
that so this is an easy one you don't
even in your calculator for this now I
owe them two hundred and fifty one
thousand six hundred and fourteen
dollars and fifty eight cents that make
sense yeah one month so over there on
the Left this is the first month this is
the first month so one months of
interests yeah you see what's going on
okay that's fine okay
they've added interest but you're gonna
be the tug of war I mentioned right so
I'm going to pay off one thousand eight
hundred and eighty eight dollars so over
here the balance what I now owe them is
that P plus I and you're gonna take away
the repayment you made though 1888 okay
so you can go ahead and you can
calculate that
I have this number what do you think yep
happy no yes
no I have subtracted 1888 that was the
repayment right over there
I have subtracted it from how much I owe
them after the interest okay
now have a look look before we look at
the next line and starts to get a bit
mechanical okay what do you make of this
number how much of a deads have you made
into your debt a pretty small amount
right uh two hundred forty nine thousand
it's about two hundred and seventy
dollars okay you'll like well I've
plowed in 1888
but the dent I made was quite small
because the tug of war is very balanced
at this point okay so that's fine now
it's like everything starts all over
again
the principal at the start of month
number two is that about you just wrote
it's the balance it's going to be two
hundred and forty nine and oh sorry
decimal point the wrong place seven
hundred twenty six and fifty eight cents
that's the new principal as it was as
well okay what am I going to do to work
out the next step however I'm gonna have
to do this with the interest calculation
again aren't I so over here this is how
I calculated interest last time I'm
gonna do it again but I'm gonna do it
with this as my principal whoops keep
doing that wrong
you see that so I've done this all over
again this interest calculation but with
my updated principle okay so I'm going
to multiply by those numbers and get
some kind of messy decimal out of it
okay
here's my number oh that's not right
then highlighter as a look yeah okay so
can you see what's happened the interest
from month two is ever so slightly
smaller than the interest from month one
why is that because the amount is
smaller we've reduced the balance that's
why these are called reducing balance
loans okay so now we're gonna add that
back well you can say it from both
perspectives I mean the whole point of
an economic transaction is there is a
win on both sides of the equation right
the bank is happy because we're paying
them these huge sums of money right but
I'm happy because I don't have this
amount of money to buy a house so I'm
enabled to do something I couldn't do
otherwise so it's kind of a win-win
right yeah okay so this is the amount
I've got here you see I've added on my
new amount of interest okay now to find
the balance at the end of the month
what's the last thing I have to do I
have to subtract that repayment of 1888
that's not the rain that are I know it's
a bit sneaky but that r is not a raid
that's the repayment okay is that big
what sense yeah okay do you see it do
you see how this is going okay now now
it's nice to get a bit repetitive so you
will get faster at doing this and
eventually the number I'm after is this
number here
what will it be after six months how
much progress will I have made on my
mortgage can you have a go at that get
done yeah I heard have a go